oh yeah this is when the IFC turns off
the lights and it's about to get sexy
IFC at midnight it turns into the
incessantly fuckin channel allso 52
seconds of logos the scene looks exactly
like someone threw glass in her face way
to make us feel like we're really in a
rekt movie movie opens up with weird
imagery and ends up being a dream but it
also really happens so it's playing more
like a memory and not a dream cliche
straight into the huge that was the end
Emilia tries to calm down Samuel and get
him back to sleep by reading him a story
about a monster even though he was
clearly concerned about a monster in the
room child magicians
amia your son's school is on the phone
children okay it's all coming together
now it is painfully obvious why this kid
looks like Alex for a Clockwork Orange
he's already into the old ultraviolence
he won't stop until he sees the crew v
draining from his three droogs if you
had any sure it's possible that a parent
wouldn't remember every book his or her
kid gets however a giant red book with
such a weird name would probably stand
out and they appear to read books every
night should raise a few alarms when it
randomly appears he can't get rid of the
babadook
roll credits a rumbling sound then three
sharp knocks it's no wonder the babadook
got fired from Monsters Inc I mean the
guy just announces his presence and
while it was effective I think the
company really got tired of this dude's
ego he wrote his own pop-up book and
everything I'm gonna hand it to this
embodiment of pure evil I mean he locked
himself up in a cabin for a solid month
with nothing but a bottle of Jack
Daniels a typewriter some construction
paper and a bottle of glue and he can
created this pop-up book to announce his
presence wherever he goes and such
beautiful binding to Jesus at least the
people who buried parallax tried
telephone number on the TV screen is
clearly American even though this movie
is shot and presumably take place in
Australia
maybe you lock the bedroom door when
you're designed to bind it up by
blocking also a movie plays the who
really entered the room while the mom is
chilling off game even though we know
it's Samuel also also while Samuel stood
at the foot of the bed and said mommy
over and over the previous time he got
scared this time he jumps in the bed and
screams because horror movies got a
horror the blue number eleven ball here
magically turns to a white sixty nine
ball here five billion anyone got five
billion amelia is a dick to old people
geez everywhere this woman look she sees
couples making out I guess this movie
subtext is about sexual frustration like
the kind of sexual frustration where you
don't have a partner
you can't masturbate in peace and the
last time you did it you had a kid where
did you get those firecrackers at the
end of the Internet age it pi also
somewhere in a dark room Al Gore sheds a
tear and tell me why did Amelia fucking
buy him fire crackers she's having
enough issues with trying to stop him
from building catapults so she's just
gonna give him easy access to other
weapons the babadook was real would say
right now for me it wants to scare you
because all ghosts demons spirits etc
feel the need to put you for an hour
before trying to kill you for the last
30 minutes
Amelia needs to brush up on her horror
101 all right time to send this kid to a
psychologist or sit in the kitchen
rubbing your temple that works too oh
and pay right now why are you letting
this child who was obviously going to
ruin Ruby's birthday party go play with
all the other children you know
someone's going to end up hurt or he'll
end up inviting the babadook in to play
with Ruby and her friends and he'll end
up being the popular one and then your
son will resent the babadook for running
with the cool crowd I do volunteer work
with some disadvantaged women and a few
of their husbands this chick was
specifically reminded not to bring up
dead dad's at the kid's birthday party
the director said let's have your
character juggle three apples it'll make
you look like thrice the asshole also
juggling also also who has a clown at a
princess party hmm I'm wondering how
Samuel pushed Ruby backwards but she
fell face-first into the lawn I'm
guessing it's because this is a
continuity mistake and Samuel is an
asshole
Claire trusts Amelia to watch the
children chick and meet mom literally I
wish we had footage of the babadook
outside placing his book down on the
welcome mat knocking on the door
retreating into the hedges and then
getting totally frustrated when Amelia
doesn't see the book on the doorstep you
ever have that annoying friend who's
always asking you to read his book when
you had the time that's mr. babadook for
you the babadook gives Emilio some tips
and tricks on his assistants rather than
just leaving her in the dark I guess a
successful demon needs to make it a
challenge or they get kicked out of the
Union Amelia received the unabridged
edition of mr. bata this time she's
lucky even the most experienced
collectors can't find this version I get
that maybe Amelia still doesn't believe
there's a monster but clearly something
is going on here so maybe you call the
police and let them know that someone or
something is in with you before you burn
the evidence also the barber cook person
answers the phone and somehow thinks
they know who's on the other line and of
course they're totally wrong cliche
that's babadook is so polite he's always
hanging up his hat and coat wherever he
goes haunting okay haunting is one thing
mother but when you unleash roaches into
a house you've gone too far
more like baba dick am i right how are
you from the drugs forgave me Sam sucks
[Music]
oh my me I'm just hanging out at a
neighbor's house who conveniently leaves
her windows open so that I can appear in
your line of sight also mrs. Roach is in
no danger
she makes me tea whenever I visit is
this a kangaroo version of Lassie like
kanga Lassie
why the same is still sleeping in
Amelia's bed if the whole point of the
pills was that they could each get a
good night's sleep in their own beds oh
it's nothing to be scared of it's just
Johnny Depp oh wait maybe we should be
scared the babadook steals from the
penny while his playbook and inserts
himself into movies media and the arts
you're that hungry why don't you go and
eat FDA regulations in Australia are a
little on the back side of things and
the babadook just with you anywhere once
you let it in that's the case then why
wasn't it showing up at the restaurant
or at the doctor's office Ruby's
birthday party this movie needs some
rules this bottled up position sort of
like being John Malkovich and Being John
Malkovich where you have to kind of
practice at being the person for a bit
before you can take full control cuz the
babadook also get thrown out onto the
New Jersey Turnpike after a few minutes
Amelia takes her masturbation which all
way too far Wow despite having a
babadook inside of her she might
actually be a better mom than she was
before I guess the real secret to
parenting is finding a balance between
way to forgiving and Psychopaths
possessed by Satan also I asked Amelia
destroyed that catapult yet or thrown it
away she barks at Samuel every time he
has it near him you have the power woman
nothing is coming in 8:00 tonight so
does the babadook show up and possess
the person who lets it in if that's the
case then why does it need the weapon
sighs long fingernails seems like it
could take care of business on its own
instead of possessing another person to
do its dirty work also how exactly does
one let the babadook get by reading the
book because the book was read four or
five nights ago so has it been in here
this whole time
nobody seems to have just come up with a
creepy creature and a name but no clue
what the fuck to do with it or any
explanation for one could say this movie
is just a big pile of Bob it up babadook
is fooled by beginners magic tricks boy
this movie went all pet sematary of the
insidious poltergeist really quick I
guess it really does get thrown out
under the New Jersey Turnpike every once
in a while wasn't the already possessing
her
nabob iudex and is actually a Casio
keyboard set on haunted house sound
effects Emilia believes that a demonic
creature is no match for a chair stuck
under a doorknob ah greatest Bob goes
through the Binaca Donna will be commit
to the cardinal sin of playing a better
movie in this case Black Sabbath then
the movie you are currently watching and
now he would rather be watching that
movie also once the babadook goes into a
toast
does it just want to watch old movies on
a crappy television also I still don't
understand why the babadook has to
possess any one clearly can attack and
scare this out of you on its own this is
just another case of ghosts just want to
have fun okay fine she killed the dog
but there wasn't anything about her
pulling her own teeth out in the revised
edition of the mr. Bob at a book I guess
it's a little tough to recreate that in
the pop-up book and all so the babadook
is essentially the home-loan script but
they removed all the comedy well he
finally did it
Sam Gulliver's travelled his mom
considering she could be bleeding out
and most likely has several concussions
she might be leaving you soon though I
don't really understand what Samuel did
to trigger this but the babadook is one
weak-ass horror villain if all it took
to beat him was the power of love or
some that would make Huey Lewis problem
also yay we won I think what's going on
here seriously if it can do all this
without entering another body then why
the fuck does it enter another body also
how did Samuel become such an expert on
the damn thing was there a missing scene
where he Ben Hanscom to himself to the
local library and did some research
while the babadook through Samuel
fruitlessly up against the wall I'd like
to know why he had to go upstairs and
why he didn't lock the door behind him
if the whole reason for this is to take
the child and copycat mr. boogie from
sinister then why hasn't he done it yet
it would be quite fitting that the way
to get rid of the babadook is to try and
get it to answer a question also the
babadook persisted I think it's gonna
rain and our town has really gotten
violence at the last time I saw it
picture frame clearly falls off the wall
in this shop and is miraculously back on
the wall in the next shop
hi Linda to the kidnapping
roar-off really that's all it baba took
[Music]
wait what it was able to go outside and
chase Amelia down in her car but I'm
sure a locked basement door will stop it
glad they were able to defeat it by find
out little one he's fine I've had the
stitches out how did one or both of them
not get sent off to either jail or some
sort of hospital I mean the mom beat the
son of the kid and the kid stabbed the
mom among other things
not to mention Amelia brutally murdered
the dog there's zero chance they
explained that off with a good story
about the babadook okay so you can't get
rid of the babadook and it seems like
now they're keeping him as some sort of
pet but can't the babadook decide for
this and terrorize some other vulnerable
family and the mother eats worms this
guy is worse than that asshole from
don't be afraid of the dark glad this
movie tied up the whether or not Samuel
becomes a good magician storyline that
was really eating on me if it's in a
word or it's in a look you can't get rid
of the pocketbook sorry as a peeping
[Music]
Tomic the taping
I find her interesting because she's a
client and because she sleeps above her
covers four feet above her covers so
bold strategy cotton let's see if it
pays off for
go and eat your Wheaties this is for
breakfast if you don't take the poo you
feel worse you take the blue pill the
story ends you wake up in your bed and
believe whatever you want to believe
everybody my age pees their pants it's
the coolest